why does the crab feeder's freaky mask
look so freaking familiar you're not
imagining it here's the surprising
connection the villain's headgear has to
game of thrones spoilers ahead
hbo's highly anticipated prequel series
house of the dragon is pulling in
massive numbers for the network proving
that viewers are happy to return to the
fantasy world of westeros and in droves
one intriguing element of the show thus
far is its swift introduction and then
justice swift killing off of the
villainous crab feeder aka cragus drajar
the crab feeder is backed by powerful
entities within the free cities who wish
to see westeros weakened
the masked greyscale afflicted baddies
served as the first major outside threat
to the targaryen protagonists however
there's also something about him that
surprisingly connects crab feeder
directly to game of thrones in an
interview with entertainment weekly crab
feeder actor daniel scott smith talked
extensively about his time as the
character on house of the dragon among
the more interesting tidbits was scott
smith confirming a cool detail about his
character's mask and its ties to a
well-known game of thrones cult the sons
of the harpy he told the outlet that he
discussed the mask with the director of
episodes 2 and 3 saying we spoke about
the idea of him being the first person
to wear this mask and it becoming iconic
and therefore it's built from that for
game of thrones why is he wearing the
mask how does he feel about that it's a
power statement so he's quite happy
wearing it well this is a fascinating
connection for house of the dragon to
make to its parent show it obviously
raises more questions than it answers
what inspired the sons of the harpy to
start wearing masks modeled after the
one that crab feeder wore is he
something of a legendary figure for them
or does it have some deeper perhaps
religious connotations and perhaps most
importantly of all will the showrunners
dive into this topic further or will it
be saved for some other far-off spin-off
series regardless it's still a big
connection between the shows that die
hard fans will no doubt appreciate damon
targaryen kills crab feeder off-screen
in episode 3 and the first serious
outside antagonist the family faces in
house of the dragon is gone in the blink
of an eye scott smith told ew that he
never even met matt smith on the set and
that it was bizarre to see his own
prosthetic corpse on tv it's a strange
experience i don't think many people
would experience that normally but it
was quite surreal it was cool though the
crab feeder never speaks but the
reappearance of the gold mask and house
of the dragon helps visually signify
that this person is an enemy of the
targaryens just as the sons of the harpy
were in game of thrones fans of the
original series will remember the
resistance group as one of daenerys
targaryen's foes in seasons 5 and 6. the
group forms to combat daenerys and her
new rule of marine the gold mask is a
representation of the harpy a gold
figure with the head and torso of a
woman and the wings tail and legs of a
bird this was a symbol of the slave
masters in slaver's bay so why crab
feeder would be wearing the same mask as
a bit of a question mark his armies are
from the free cities so perhaps this
gold mask is just a way for house of the
dragon to identify a foe of house
targaryen or perhaps it was just
something thrown in for game of thrones
stands daniel scott smith admitted that
was a factor in his ew interview saying
it was definitely a nod to that for i
guess the fans because it's something
familiar for them